well hello there watching the press
preview a first look at what is on the
front pages of friday's papers
in the next half hour then we'll see
what's making the headlines tonight
i'm joined by the columnist carol malone
and the editor of the courier
in dundee david clegg super to see both
of you get your thoughts in there in
just a moment front pages then first of
all we start with the metro
united in grief but so far apart is the
metro's lead which says
the two estranged princes will not be
walking side by side
at prince philip's funeral on saturday
similarly the sun
has the headline brothers at arm's
length
and the male 2 which splashes with
brothers
apart according to the daily telegraph
before he died the duke of edinburgh was
deeply involved in the planning of the
ceremony
meanwhile the guardian reports that
government officials have raised
concerns about the expansion of covet 19
testing due to the number of false
positives associated
with rapid turnaround tests the
financial times leading with what it
says is a looming takeover battle for
the drug making giant glaxosmithkline
david's paper the courier has a story
casting doubt on the election spending
pledges
of the snp leader and fest minister
nicholas sturgeon
and bringing up the rear the star
features a story about a man who was
fined
do i have to say this for passing wind
on a police officer
pardon me indeed pardon me i'm not sure
about that one
checking your list it's not there i hope
not uh caramel and david clegg are here
um well lots of coverage after a
briefing today on the
the finer details of the ceremony carol
let's start with you on saturday
including the news from the daily
telegraph that 18 years of planning
by the duke has led to these plans
notwithstanding of course the
streamlining of all of this because of
of covid yeah i mean he
even without covid he had planned this
funeral himself
over a long period of time and and you
know it seems like a bizarre thing for
anyone to do
to plan their own funeral however you
just know
that if anyone could do it
dispassionately
and unemotionally it would be prince
philip you know he knows it has to be
done he
he always said he never wanted a big
fuss and so he he wanted to simply and i
love the fact
the hearse is this land rover
thing it looks like a big truck and it's
painted in military green
and it's going to be flanked by various
military personnel reflecting
all the kind of the you know the
services he supported you know the
military the navy
the royal marines uh and i love the fact
it's it's almost like he was cocking a
snoop
at at tradition by having this kind of
hearse
it's it's absolutely him and it actually
it when i when i was reading about this
today oddly enough it made me smile
because i thought
you know even in death he is still
directing things
exactly as he did in life when he was
you know although he always walked
two steps behind the queen while the
pair of them were on duty
he was always absolutely the boss in his
own household
and in life and and this fuel is
absolutely indicative of that and i i
i like it it's good yes and you you
wonder if there's a sense of humor that
goes through some of it
including the naval call action stations
uh
which will be sounded a specific request
for it which is given at sea
to summon all hands to battle stations
performed by the buglers
of the royal marines not often heard the
telegraph tells us
at funerals although anyone connected to
the royal navy can request it and he
firmly was connected to the royal navy
and had deep connections too uh with
many
other military outfits um david which
will be in full sight
and sound at the funeral on saturday
yes indeed uh his service in the royal
navy will be
quite prominent in the service and i
think that does show his individuality
some of the choices there
i believe that the the him uh eternal
fowler strong to save
will uh be uh played as well uh alas
because of the covert regulations
that there can't be congressional
singing but the it will be played
uh and and that will also be another uh
reference to
to his time in the in the royal navy so
i i do certainly think that there has
been
the stamp of his uh individual character
uh all over the the service as it's been
outlined
uh and despite the fact that those plans
have had to be changed quite
considerably
given the the the pairing down that's
had to be done
to uh accommodate the covid regulations
it is still very much going to be a
service that has his pa
personality right through it i think yes
absolutely and there is that
uh land rover defender td5 130
which he'd been modifying since 2003
we're told
um and that that is the the detail that
we'll be looking out for
um there's a lot of background noise
though isn't there if we look at the
other newspapers
uh the male the sun and so on which is
about the fact that the
the two princes um the grandsons harry
and william
will not be walking um next to each
other um
you know we will be looking out for this
stuff too won't we carol
um even though you know you know
the telegraph has a line that the uh the
queen's final preparations aim to steer
the royal family into carmel waters
that's camilla tommy writing
um you know this anyone who
thought that this funeral might actually
heal the rift between the two brothers
i mean this was it's never going to
happen it was never going to happen
you know not weeks after uh prince harry
has labelled
his family racist and and after
he you know he allowed his wife megan to
attack
wills's wife kate and and say quite
hurtful things about her so
this rift is not going to be healed and
this is such a shame because i think
on this day when we should all be
remembering
uh prince philip everyone is going to be
watching
these two young men we're going to be
watching their reactions to each other
we're going to be watching their
reaction to the day
they've been told they cannot walk
together they're being separated
by peter phillips princess and son which
is
both ridiculous and sad in a way you
know they
that you know that day of all days the
two of them
should actually do stuff together but
clearly they are
so badly estranged that they won't walk
together and it's i mean
except for peter phillips is the oldest
grandchild and it could just be that
you know that gives him no you you're
you're shaking yourself i don't i don't
think so not for a nanosecond i believe
they've been separated because
they are so badly estranged and everyone
doesn't say everyone is going to be
watching them which i think is a shame
because
all attention should be on what's
happening with the funeral and
and on our queen and we should be
supporting her but instead people are
going to be watching for facial
expressions they're going to be
interpreting what they think they see
what they don't see and and it's going
to detract attention i think
from the funeral itself david you were
trying to come on
yeah i mean i can't i can't uh boast
about any great
insight into the family dynamics the
personal dynamics between between the
royal family but what i would say is
that
this this soup opera between william and
harry is
is something that quite a few of the
papers are leading on tomorrow and carol
is certainly right that it's going to
attract a lot of attention during the
funeral but but something about the way
this funeral has been laid out the fact
that it's
it's it's quite an intimate affair
because only 30 people can can
attend because of the covert regulations
uh
his family from germany are attending as
well
and we know that megan of course is is
not making the trip on on medical advice
because she's pregnant
and you know there is something i think
quite humanizing about it that there is
this tension in the family as there is
in all families
and you know these these types of
moments are times when when families can
reunite and
when these kind of situations can
resolve themselves so i don't i don't
know if i share carl's uh cynicism and
pessimism
to quite that extent that there couldn't
be a resolution here i i think that uh
william and harry have been very close
uh as we know
uh as brothers uh throughout their lives
and
you know nothing can be overcome and not
be overcoming those situations
seriously david do you really think this
is weeks after
harry branded will's family racist he
had to defend his family in public
and say we are not racist and and megan
attacked his wife you seriously think
that that a couple of two or three weeks
after that
that there's going to be some kind of
reconciliation i don't believe it for
another second
and frankly i don't blame william for
not actually
forgiving him at this point if he
doesn't choose to and i don't think he
will because i think if there'd been any
hint
of a reconciliation they would have
walked together
they wouldn't be going to these lenses
to keep them apart
is there not an argument that if they
were together that there would be even
closer scrutiny on what's going on and
perhaps this has been some attempt to
manage that so that doesn't cause any
problems
i think what what happens on cameron in
that moment of the day will probably not
be where that could happen but certainly
they'll have an opportunity to talk
afterwards at some other point during
the weekend so
you never you never knew what would
happen i wouldn't be uh so skeptical
that nothing could
uh emerge from that yes one of the
papers was certainly suggesting that
possibly if if the uh the cambridges
have moved back to kensington palace for
the start of school
having been up in norfolk there there
might be chance of another meeting
as you say in the days following the
funeral um but
but the decision to try and calm things
down uh is also the decision
to get people to wear suits isn't it
because harry the most recent
active service member of the family
would not be allowed to wear them so
he would feel bad so you know the queen
is being practical
to be fair the duke of edinburgh is is
known as a practical man too
and really at the heart of this now
because of covid
it's almost like you've got a private
family funeral but with the cameras
allowed to watch in
you know a few broadcasters in in the in
the chapel grounds as it were
which takes us to the metro and the
tears of charles for his papa
going there to look at the tributes
today the floral tributes the flowers
the messages laid out at uh
at the home now of the commonwealth um
and the family will be feeling this
deeply
as you say a real force carol um
at home and and and away i really
felt for charles particularly today
i mean he looked really distraught at
one point
and you know and he especially he saw
that someone had left
um a little land rover um with the duke
on with the woods it was a tory land
river with the duke on top
and he looked really moved by that you
know it's
it's very difficult isn't it when you're
when your dad has died and everyone is
watching your every move
but his eyes were very teary and
camilla's were too it's very hard to
read
those kind of heartfelt messages and and
not be moved i mean he's grieving his
dad but he's also
looking at the grief of other people and
it's look at his face there i mean he
looks
he looks tortured and just very briefly
david
we've talked about all eyes on you know
the brothers and their body language
actually the image will be her majesty
the queen in black she's normally in
very bright colors
wearing a face mask and sitting on her
own i mean it's kind of
devastating as it has been for people up
and down this country during the
pandemic
yes indeed i think there is something
quite moving about that because
uh so so many families have uh had to
bury
loved ones in the last year uh and not
in the way they would want to in reduced
circumstances with people that they they
love and cherish that couldn't be there
uh so i think there will be something
quite moving for for everyone about that
image of the
queen being in that situation as well
and of course the the poignancy of
of anyone uh burying their their husband
after such a long marriage
uh it's unimaginable really for most of
us to think what that type of
longevity in a relationship must be like
so so i think it will be quite an
emotional day
yes i'm sure many people will empathize
certainly uh with her
and and that experience um more from you
in just a moment thank you for now
still to come we'll talk about the
eyebrows raised by david cameron's
lobbying activities that's
in just a moment
well welcome back you're watching the
press preview with me now carol malone
and david clegg welcome back to both of
you
um carol let's delve inside the metro um
eyebrows raised i raised an eyebrow a
few people are raising eyebrows aren't
they about the
the lobbying row amid uh well multiple
inquiries now it seems
yeah both i mean this is deeply
humiliating
for cameron on every level because he's
being investigated by
an investigation launched by boris the
man he he holds responsible for having
to resign after the 2016 referendum and
you know it's snowballing this story in
the beginning it just
looked like there was there was one
white or mandarin you know on his watch
who was working for green so now we're
we're learning we're learning about this
this
today we learned of a guy called sir
john manzoni
and uh he was also working for green
cell while he was
chief executive for the civil service
now this is you know
this is actually quite frightening this
is this is terribly
reputationally damaging for cameron
um you know and i but i think we've got
to look beyond just the detail that
we're saying in this you know we've got
to look beyond this and look at ordinary
people how they view this you know
they're looking at these mandarins who
are paid 150 grand plus a year most of
them more than the prime minister
and and and they're there and plus their
gold plated pensions and all the other
perks they get
and these smart and the 12 people 150
plus is not a year
is not enough for them they have to have
other jobs and you can't tell me if
they're if they're being paid
a hundred grand a year by a company like
greenfield that they're doing their job
as a as a top civil servant property it
just
you know it's it's like this elitist
group if you get into
in government circles you get into the
club
you get into the old boys club you're
set for life and it just
looks greedy and grasping
and and just it just reinforces the
belief that a lot of people have
that politicians are only in the job for
what they can get for themselves and it
certainly looks this way now cameron
insists he's broken
no rules well he may not have broken a
rule but what he's done
doesn't look right and it looks like an
abuse of power and that's what we're
seeing
there is a clear abuse of power
inside government and it's it's the rich
and the well-connected
getting richer and it's and it's it's
terrible to see
yeah i think she moved the camera just
show how tidy your kitchen was there
actually looks like a hotel
i've just been in i've just been trying
to get murphy because you ran away
you've gone outside
it's not searching for the husband
to talk about your front page so if you
don't mind in 45 seconds take it away
okay so uh it's the hollywood election
in scotland next month
the snp are going to win that election
we know that it's
it's almost certain that they will
remain in government so their manifesto
launch which
which was today is very significant it
is extremely ambitious
it suggests that in the next
parliamentary term nicholas sturgeon
plans to invest billions more on the
health service on an education and
infrastructure
she's pledged to freeze income tax rates
and bans and also hold a second
independence referendum before the end
of 2023
now there could be some roadblocks into
that uh the ifs
has said the the spending pledges
haven't been
properly costed and would require a lot
of tricky trade-offs
and the prime minister boris johnson
said he wouldn't grant a second
referendum
so i think we can be pretty confident
that nicolas sturgeon's going to be
re-elected
how much of that manifesto she manages
to implement over the next five years is
more of an open question
interesting it's very fascinating there
was a lot of shaking heads from carol
but
carol maybe we'll talk about that
david and uh carol thank you both very
much we'll see you then thank you